[Music]
lighthouse point an exclusive community
six miles outside of boca raton florida
lined with large mansions pristine
beaches and home to la bistro
after studying its top michelin star
restaurants throughout europe andy
truesdale met and married the love of
his life ellen come on here
andy and i met in saint thomas at the
restaurant that he was executive chef
and i fell in love with his food it was
love at first bite
i've worked in a chef in many different
areas in big hotels small hotels little
restaurants and i can run rings around
anyone
anyone
tired of working for other people they
moved to south florida in 2001 to
fulfill andy's dream of opening up a
restaurant of his own
good evening the bistro restaurant can i
help you
hello
ellen and myself decided to buy a
restaurant because she obviously tried
my food she realized how dedicated i was
and i'm very on the ball with everything
hey what's that [ __ ] over there get off
the shelf get that off there
andy is not only a chef he's a creator
don't forget my apples you need apples
cut three nice rings i would really say
he's a master at what he does and if i
didn't think my husband was a brilliant
chef i would not be in this business
with him fella
i'm right here
[Music]
table 14 is ready for the entree i'm
gonna run this now there seems to be a
lot of wealth in the area but for some
reason the people that live in
lighthouse point do not seem to
appreciate andy's food idea they didn't
want it they don't want anything else
just drew dry the problem is he think
he's perfect so he
really don't like it when people turn
back to food steak is grizzly
get the [ __ ] out of here that's
beautiful beef tenderloin they're a
local custard i don't give a [ __ ]
alex this is your fault you sought it
out my food's perfect i've worked long
and hard and paid for the right to have
what i want be quiet whether people come
and like it love it or hate it it's my
business it's my reputation it's my food
i'm the chef and i'm the owner that's
what i want
i really wish i knew what the major
problem with le bistro was i can't say
it's the food
of course i can't say it's me
i don't believe it's my staff
i just don't know what the problem is
be happy don't be
it's a bistro it's fun it's upbeat right
now i can't keep up with the debt
and i don't know where we're going to
get the money to pay the debt off
it's going from bad to worse
for the work and the effort everything
we're doing everything we've put into
this would definitely not benefit
anything
if this restaurant closes
last thing i want to do is go and work
for some idiot somewhere else
i hate idiots
[Music]
south florida known for many great
things great beaches water sports and a
place where people like to dine out le
bistro is chef phoned and he's on his
ass now today he's close to lunch
because he's holding a cooking class i'm
about to pay him a surprise visit
here we go
uh the menu is a goat cheese that we
have on the menu and we put a little
beet pollen on you arrange it so it
looks like a flower
[Music]
oh hi hello good afternoon hello ladies
gentlemen good afternoon
nice to see you please don't let me stop
how are you hello bomb nice to meet you
very much you're happy what's the matter
uh just right in the middle and i'm
behind the key first impression i had
when gordon ramsay walked in the door
was what the [ __ ] is he doing here
so what's for entree chef i just thought
we'd do like a little minute steak a
little sirloin
nice
hello
nice to meet you nice to meet you here
are you the
server uh she's my wife oh she's your
wife
lucky lady
so maybe like a large dice bring them up
to the boil then simmer for about 15
minutes and i'm gonna put a little bit
of butter in there
[Music]
should it be smoking
so that's okay we obviously just paid a
little smoke um
[Music]
i felt like gordon ramsay was just being
an actor
[Music]
thank you very much i've enjoyed it nice
to see you
thank you very much thank you
so how do you think that went happy with
it
uh not really
what's the matter those cooking classes
go very very well for us i don't want
you to [ __ ] it up to try and make a
mockery of what i'm doing in front of
these people
jesus
are you always like this or always like
one so defensive
you ask me a question i'm answering you
okay so let's line up a little bit come
over danny please
so where did you start cooking andy i'd
work for uh michelle in london you
worked for michelle wrote the water sign
in yeah that's exactly what happened to
me so we had a very similar sort of
training honestly from a chef's point of
view you've got your
stripes so in your mind the one single
reason to why the ration's not working
helen will be what for some reason
people don't find it appealing to come
in here and i mean the locals we our
bread and butter clientele don't seem to
enjoy the restaurant they're not biting
people
really and truly
are pretty demanding
never fed up with it
has a business ever worked in nine years
now
never it's gone up and down it's never
been great andy ellen said your dear
wife said very quickly no if it's never
worked don't be embarrassed i'm not
well i'm just saying that
she's wrong
right i'd like to eat
seen the cooking class fantastic resume
and i'd love to taste your food anything
yeah show off show me what you're made
of i'll just take it off the menu yeah
i don't know what chef ramsay's going to
say because andy's food is very good and
he somehow manages to stay ahead of the
trends all the time with his menus and
his recipes just as we always do that's
not changing nothing we don't have two
or three people cooking on the stove
it's me on the self listen you're going
to hand me that [ __ ] out of that fridge
but no [ __ ] around if i say i want it
this way i want it that way because i
said i've earned it i'm paying for it
okay just a minute for the lamb and
we're gonna have everything else coming
right out
nice to meet you good night gordon
[Music]
alex do your job let's go
okay oh here's the react
bon appetit thank you
[Music]
i think i just chipped my tooth
like that cartilage christ show him the
bone as well jesus
[Music]
i'm just busting my tooth here man he
found your bones on his duck
listen go away go away he doesn't listen
to nobody that's it that's the way he is
you cannot change andy nice
[Music]
jesus coconut curry
jalapeno oh my god garlic coconut lamb
inside the it is okay uh-huh did you
show chef to college yeah i did he uh
told me to like go go away did you want
to talk about it
that's the truth
[Music]
it's a rubbery
huh
the texture of the lamb is very rubbery
mediterranean crispy fried lamb curry
roll
i'm in florida not in mumbai
you hate it or whatever
this is [ __ ]
this is just a fucker's up nah that's
not why whatever i'd stop right there if
i'll go away
gordon ramsay trashed everything i did i
think that's his whole goal is to
[ __ ] all over you make you feel bad
okay uh
right that was interesting so that was
you at your best
that wasn't my best that i've ever done
in my career you mean for the best here
or you mean is that the best food that
we have
yes or no i mean i you know was that i
asked you to cook for me and just yeah
just tell me how that was for you uh
that was good for this restaurant it's
good for here
[Music]
here's the problem
the food's old-fashioned i'm totally
totally out of text in terms of where
you are that's your opinion
the food is sad
stuck in the 80s possibly the most
shocking dish anywhere in florida the
crispy lamb roll
what in the hell was going on when we
put that one together shredded coconut
horrible rubbery texture almost
on the verge of being depressing
any more you want to put me down for
[Music]
the briet i don't know if anyone gave
you feedback but it was on the verge of
breaking my tooth all right i'm supposed
to believe that
you're not looking at me now as if i'm
exaggerating it was full of cartilage
i'm listening to what you're saying
nobody i didn't know no one told me no
one told you
hey man he found their bones under the
dirt
that doesn't go away two seconds sir
yeah do you not tell the chef that the
first mouthful was full of cartilage
yeah i did
i mean i told him he told me to go away
when your waiter comes to tell you
valuable information you should know
those kind of things right
[Music]
can i just have two minutes with andy in
my own would you mind ellen would you
mind
honestly yeah straight up
i'm here to help
so far all you're doing is just slam me
down that's all you've done with me i
think it's about you blame me i know you
he's not my chef he's not
we don't work for him you're the chef
owner right
so why won't you take responsibility
i'm the chef you don't like it
that's fine it's your opinion you don't
like it we're [ __ ] we're no good i'm
lousy whatever
[ __ ] me do you have issues
in the short time that chef ramsay has
been at the bistro he is already feeling
very uncomfortable with the arrogant
owner that cooked the food you don't
like it we're [ __ ] but no good i'm
lousy whatever now it's time to see how
this tiny south florida restaurant
handles its customers in a dinner
service i gotta take del ordinaire come
to you okay
i'm the only one who takes the water
it's a joke
those are actually working ones
or is that
the way they do it
i would love to be able to just take the
orders but andy only wants one person
writing the checks seriously
it's alexander takes orders in there yes
one person takes the orders and it slows
down things for andy
i've just noticed two tables that are
waiting to get their order taken okay
i'll go out and see what's happening
hi how are you very awesome
do you know what you'd like okay who
would like to start
oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
so would you usually pull out everything
when he calls an order on so he can get
it on the fire so do you actually cook
as well or not i can but annie does not
let me code
this is definitely a little kingdom here
isn't it it's a one-man band
hey hey hey we don't have time for
talking i don't care if it's him or the
queen
just keep going over that refrigerator
you look on there and go over everything
wow
[Music]
who's is this writing that's me why
because why are you doing that you're
going against everything we said and
everything we did i'm sorry we're going
get back here
you're [ __ ] up enough tonight
people are really dumb sometimes and
they think with their ass rather than
their brain
it's an hour into dinner service and
this part chef part dictator has now
allowed a few entrees to leave his
kitchen andy
am i ready to take this
we waiting for you yeah the fries are
there i don't know what you want me to
do it grows on the plate okay madness
are you a gentleman hi thank you for
your patience
it's it's inevitable yeah even well done
it's really too round for me i like it
well but not short
yeah okay thank you
andy
she wants it well but not charred he has
to meet him well let's meet him well she
wants it more i don't care we're not
doing it again no
so go back and tell her choose something
else
houston we have a situation
i'm very sorry but the chef would like
you to make a different choice
[Music]
this is unbelievable because there's a
lot of similarities between andy and i
we're both english and we both studied
in paris but there's one thing we don't
share in common i care about my
customers he clearly doesn't give a [ __ ]
what a shame
[Music]
hey india i say it's terrible bro what's
terrible about it he wants to be the
writer tom go [ __ ] himself yeah
why are you looking for excuses and
every [ __ ] table has come back all
you want to do is argue with them look
at the potatoes they're black
so [ __ ] sad
well all you've done is slammy's the
second you've been here and that's what
you do right why are you acting like
this i don't get it
you don't have to get
it andy
seriously you don't give a [ __ ] big boy
you're looking for a justification every
time you [ __ ] up
a man that can't even accept his own
mistakes i'll get you started white
you're asking it's brilliant chef you're
amazing treat your wife like a [ __ ]
dog
don't put my wife into it i'm gonna do
it
don't bring my [ __ ] wifi don't you
[ __ ] go there you don't point that
[ __ ] out the [ __ ]
i'll just calm down i just asked
politely don't talk to like that you
haven't got respect for her how can you
get people working for you yeah whatever
this is [ __ ]
[Music]
after getting nowhere with andy in the
kitchen just before you leave would you
be so kind just to fill out these
customer common cards sure gordon steps
outside not only to cool off but to get
some feedback from the clientele
okay
something andy has never done
i ask your customers leaving the
restaurant this evening to rate the
service out of 10 to rate the food to
rate the experience
so
on average 4 out of 10 for the service
on that note
why do you take all the tables
order that's what they want who oh me
so what's the rationale behind it the
logic it helps the space a little bit it
buys a few minutes
there's three of you in the kitchen
like i said i don't know if you're hard
of hearing but
there's one person cooking
that's me
food they rated
three out of ten
but the most important question was
would they come back
and about 78 of them
said no
and the weird thing about the whole
service tonight
every time something comes back as far
as you're concerned your customers are
wrong
oh that's your evaluation that's what i
watched
don't make you right of me wrong about
every single thing
oh my god
you have to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] because
you had like such a dick everybody's
[ __ ] it's like a competition between
you and i
you don't intimidate me what kind of
them bully me that's all you're trying
to [ __ ] do you're so wrapped up in a
deluded little bubble
and not one person has got the balls to
tell you the truth is not working
you are
blatantly ignorant
whatever
[ __ ] you come on
you're one-sided that's all you want to
[ __ ] do
excuse me
it was a miserable evening in which chef
ramsay tried continually to get through
to andy that's your evaluation oh my god
but this stubborn chef flatto refuses to
listen you just don't want to get better
do you
you've never ever ever understood the
value of your customers let alone your
staff
because you don't give a [ __ ] about them
i'm a loser everybody
i'm the worst
anything else anymore
guys can you give me two minutes on my
own please
guys can you just
back off please
would you mind
yeah
hey everybody
everybody out
indian man he's an [ __ ]
we could never tell him that because he
won't listen he won't listen to nobody
do you want your restaurant to work yes
or no obviously yes okay good but stop
there that's the most honest you've been
all day
you don't need to be so defensive with
me tonight was about observing watching
the [ __ ] setup you have created a
monster here what are the suggestion are
you committed to making this place
change
that's all i need to know before i'm out
of here that that is it yeah you can
change everything
no no i need to hear it from
you you you you andy
you
thank you i'll see you in the morning
good night get some sleep
[ __ ] me [ __ ] you now
gentlemen good night one stubborn [ __ ]
huh
andy's statement that he is open to
change has kept chef ramsay around for
at least another day
but gordon is fully aware that he is at
the beginning of a huge uphill battle
take a sink
sit down and relax how cool is this
terrific
right i wanted to come out and clear the
air
because of
the stigma and your training and the
proudness that's defense mechanism
but before we start changing you have to
understand that we have to identify the
problems with the restaurant you've got
to understand where you've gone wrong
and when you've come downstairs and i've
got a little surprise for you sam which
would be nice sandwich
stop thinking about your tummy
now come down because in this door okay
i've arranged for you to meet
some very special people
good morning ladies and gentlemen
how are we good to see you
in this room are your
previous customers and they've got some
very important information
to tell you about their experience
the last time they ate at the bistro
madam tell me the experience what was it
like
it just in general did not live up to
our expectations and was not at all what
we expected for a bistro what was the
biggest disappointment across the whole
experience the food
the food
auntie anything to sing
nothing to say
nothing anyone else
we were there a year or so ago none of
us can remember the experience we didn't
even know the restroom was still in
business until we said i don't really
want to come in
because i i don't want to get into it
isn't this valuable information
[Music]
when did you eat at the bistro what was
it last time i've eaten there twice the
last time was probably about a year ago
i described the experience you know you
walk through the door it's kind of dark
gloomy there's no one in there at all
you know and then you sit down and eat
and you know it's like you have everyone
staring at you when you're sitting there
eating you know it's just very
uncomfortable honestly deep down are you
looking for naked women dancing on the
table
well looking for hey relax
what are you looking for relax right
relax they don't want to see naked
dancers on the table come on andy
these are customers
he didn't want to hear about it it was a
wall that andy had around him but he
needs to listen to what the people are
saying why'd you take it so personally
this is really not nice for us so i got
to suck it up right now
it's not personal yeah thank you
so getting you guys here today was
valuable for me to understand where
we're going wrong i'm sure
andy nelly will take the information the
right text
but thank you
in spite of andy again refusing to take
advantage of any feedback chef ramsay
pushes on to another problem in the
restaurant andy's inability to delegate
anything to his sous chef to make his
life easier yeah i'll do the dish with
you and tonight as we service henry can
cook the dish
so is he gonna do that dish he's gonna
purely cook one snapper just to make
your life easier or whatever
my are you all right by the way you
don't look very happy we seem like
you've got into a little bubble again
okay great have you cooked snapper
before yes yeah good getting on the
stove be nice tonight cooking you know
snapper dish help speed up just to get
food out if you square it up the fish
cooks evenly yes yeah and nothing's
overcooked on the outside fishing always
lay away from you yeah skin side down
fingers on the top i wish rather still
weird i could keep in there my concern
was is that i was going to cook the fish
properly and get it out in time take
your fish
beautifully glazed and sit that on top
of your vinaigrette would you like
little cakes first yeah yeah
ellen please
local core snapper and more importantly
right now pretty good for the bottom
line
in terms of profit-wise
that's really good i love the dish it
was delicious hopefully we'll sell most
of the specials tonight and hendrick
will be taking some of the pressure off
of andy andy i know you're busy giving a
little taste
[Music]
yeah
very good
[Music]
in spite of his frustration and
disappointment with andy
chef ramsay has taken a number of steps
to make sure tonight's dinner service
will be smoother
we'll do temples of this stuff tonight
okay gordon has created a new tasty
profitable snapper special lay away from
you so you don't splash
he has insisted that sous chef hendrick
will cook hi welcome to le bistro and
lastly he's made sure that both waiters
will be taking orders which are your
tables i got this side with different
waiters taking the order at the same
time it's easy to accommodate customers
the whole place should run as a team we
have some great specials tonight we're a
local cot red snapper i'd like to have a
snack you just had a little taste i
finished the thing
it was so good now that both waiters are
taking orders one of chef ramsay's goals
has been realized order is orders are
getting into the kitchen much quicker
four bistros in the middle one marty and
three snapper
order in
juan capacio and escargo in order guys
hurt
[Music]
the only question is
can andy handle it and order in tell me
where to fire those snappers andy
not yet because the duck's gonna be a
few minutes
what table's next
i'm trying to do this one here
i need to fire that snap or no hang on i
don't want you firing on me being ready
30 minutes into service and the kitchen
is already behind hendrick is waiting on
the sideline for andy to tell him what
to do and andy is still cooking one dish
at a time
andy what's going on with six i'm still
missing the molly on the last table that
came on order that ticket's like a hot
potato in your hand get it out
waiting on that
it's not making sense ellen it's not
making sense he'll get it
i know he will i still think andy needs
to get up to par he can't do everything
himself and he needs more support back
there
i need all the entrees now alan don't
make matters worse it's bad enough
having him on my ass i'm just saying six
has been there forever
this is a joke that's one hour ten
minutes now not one entree served he has
a restaurant next door to him i'm about
to prove a very important point
how are you good evening busy night here
tonight huh yeah would you mind if i
order to go no not at all i will go for
the tuna okay how long about 10 minutes
thank you so much
there's still no nonsense can you
believe that
well that's 10 minutes this restaurant
on average 75 to 80 minutes for an
entree let's go
[Music]
ready yes it is excellent does food
always come out that quick yes thank you
[Music]
incredible well
[Music]
that is absolutely delicious there's
somebody else that really needs to know
about this now
[Music]
still no entrees
[Music]
oh god
something i need to show you very
quickly out of the frustration in terms
of why food's taking so long
i decided to do a little experiment i
ran in there ordered an entree tuna they
came out
10 minutes
they
are full i'm just trying to show you
what's happening on your doorstep
we're going to have to have a serious
talk
by the way it was delicious
[Music]
let me know when i need to send those
snappers are you ready
uh can you just give me a second just so
i can get these out yup send the snapper
so you can focus and get quicker out of
the box go go go
after chef ramsay's constant prodding
hendrick begins to cook
don't fire one snapper go for it tonight
you reclaim your position as a sous chef
do a good job he'll trust you more
snapper they snap us at the window and
now that hendrick is focused on cooking
his specials at least some entrees are
leaving the kitchen snapper for you oh
there we go look at that
thank you
yeah this snapper is really good
chef ramsay snapper cooked by hendrick
is getting positive reviews you cook my
fish
[Music]
give me the plate
there's pink he never cooks the way you
want [ __ ] sake
i'm really sorry
i cannot believe that you're happy to
serve that if they wanted more cook why
can't you just cook it i don't need to
tell you big boy this is your restaurant
i'm so sorry
but now you've ever stepped the mark
now we still had my dog
after another dinner service filled with
customer complaints
chef ramsay tries once again to get
through to andy
tonight honestly i was disappointed
because you proved
yet again
that you don't give a [ __ ]
about your customers you're in the
service industry customer relations
do you want to hear anything i have to
say about it to answer oh please there's
no point you're just badgering me you
don't want to hear anything i say
talk to me
chef my name's andy
isn't one of the problems that the
customers here are different than your
experience of customers in europe that
is that is part of the truth
people don't here understand
any form of
food or service really truly but you
can't afford to be a snob i'm not a snob
you just told me you know they don't
know what they're talking about you just
said it yourself
you've got to come down
peg
i know chefs that would give their right
arm to have their wife at the front the
chef at the helm and a neighborhood
family run business
it's a dream come true for any chef i
wasn't [ __ ] given it i earned it good
it wasn't given to me on a [ __ ] place
so don't throw it away
you're about to blow it
completely
we're at that point
we're at that point
you you've brought it to light
you've came and you've told us and
you've showed us and you've brought it
to life
you can win if you want to
andy wipe the slate clean
and start again
that's the best thing to do
tomorrow
together
all three of us
are gonna relaunch this restaurant
tomorrow is the beginning of a new
chapter
wipe the slate clean
good night
with andy's first real commitment to
change
chef ramsay brings in his renovation
team to work through the night to
transform la bistro
[Music]
right good morning good morning how are
you hi thank you
how are you
how are you great yeah good you look
great
now andy last night you told me you were
committed to changing this restaurant
yes yes
good because today's about change yes
this is your new restaurant
have a look at your new site
oh my goodness oh that's fabulous
modern legible is it nice i love it it's
well overdue i love the sign it seems
like easy on the eye ready to go inside
have a look oh yes let's go
[Music]
come in
[Music]
oh beautiful wow
this is great gone are the booths oh
thank god
in comes this wonderful leather
upholstered wall comfy bonquette seating
take a seat
ah
i like this
happy happy very good extremely happy
it's great i i'm stuck for words really
because it's a big change for us i mean
i've been here almost nine years to see
something in just a few minutes it's
like a shock wow
oh my goodness it's great
it was great to see andy as happy as he
is i'm so relieved i'm really looking
forward to see him in the kitchen i
think he's truly capable of change this
is the beginning of a new chapter that's
what we needed that's for sure this is
what you needed and if this doesn't
rekindle that spirit and that level of
passion
i don't know what will
[Music]
chef ramsay spent most of relaunch day
cooking side by side with andy put your
pan yup nice and hot what else you got
left to do for service i'm just
finishing the polenta gordon is hoping
these new menu dishes will be just what
the local community wants uh right how
does the food look that's great doesn't
it lovely the gazpacho perfect for a hot
summer's evening oysters local oysters
extraordinary steam mussels i would
order that perfect have a taste
andre's local snapper big hit last night
it's remaining on the menu
it's quite straightforward and for me
the secret tonight is the speed
a little apprehensive because someone
else's menu but time for change and
change is better
of course we're happy
that is so good
now
everybody
this is crucial tonight each one of your
tables
will play host
to a phenomenal
vip that is going to spread the word
beyond belief
over there the chief of police over
there that gentleman is the city
commissioner
over here we have the host of the top
radio morning show and there's also the
local renowned food critic
from the newspaper this is fabulous
thank you pretty excited to be cooking
for the vips obviously they have a big
pole so
um looking forward to hopefully keeping
them happy i want to know why they
haven't been here before
[Music]
with a completely new game plan in place
so when it comes on you put on there you
just take it right absolutely beautiful
la bistro is ready to open its doors and
there will be a local vip at virtually
every table in the restaurant oh i'm so
anxious i'm glad you're here there you
are thank you we have great new summer
menu this snapper beautiful comes with a
little arugula and then i'll try these
snappers please i'm gonna have the
risotto on your recommendation i'm gonna
try your snapper i think that sounds
really interesting
yeah who is he's one of the top chefs
from south florida
he's very very famous
le bistro's success tonight rests on
andy's ability to cook you and he ever
got to connect now yeah and his ability
to delegate can you keep it knees ring
here we go
you ready yep ordering i feel like it's
a risotto a pork a snap and a burger
guys come on
yes hendrick make sure they're nice
you're gonna need fries for burger need
that right away
[Music]
for you
look at them
[Music]
andy got off to a good start and
customers are enjoying the new menu very
good
but back in the kitchen things are
starting to heat up
let me know when i can fire that second
snapper and andy is slipping back to his
old ways what do we need
chicken risotto lamb burger
andy
yeah you've just gone silent last 15
minutes not saying a word but we're
going as fast as we can andy
don't go back the old ways all right
hustle
you are doing table 13. 14 and five has
been cool that's what we're doing don't
you dare go the wrong table come on hey
come on go go go go go
go
where's a [ __ ] snapper i need two
snapper on the table ready or not coming
with it jeff leave that i'll do that
you don't want to send these to you
they can go with these they just go in
the window
andy
can we go with these come here two
seconds please jeff
what the [ __ ] is going on there this
one's more cooked than normal chef come
here you a minute come here just just
just 30 seconds
out of the way of everybody
[Music]
i need two snaps on the table ready or
not it's relaunch night and the pressure
is starting to get to ending come on
give me that [ __ ] thing
they can go with these they're just
going to end up old habits are returning
and the food preparation is suffering
andy what the [ __ ] is going on there
this one's more cooked than normal chef
come here you a minute just just just 30
seconds
another wave
[Music]
you can't just send [ __ ]
why now do we do this sorry chef let me
do one why do you have to cook every
[ __ ] order we're just about to serve
two plates of [ __ ]
one mushy [ __ ] useless piece of
[ __ ] crap bit of fish and one cook to
[ __ ]
why are you looking away
talk to me
jeff i didn't quite catch him
there's no excuse chef
you were running around doing everything
i don't get it
where's the standards
[Music]
you're right i admit that
you coming in big eye opener
gordon ramsay's a mean nasty son of a
[ __ ] it's a lesson in tough love it's a
wake-up call just that i didn't see it
right till the very end
we can't come this far now and flake at
the end huh
you know what no because this has to go
and i suppose he doesn't have to go i'm
pretty sorry i'm sorry i i'm generally
sorry he works his ass off all night you
look like a star and then look we come
to this you've got more proudness in you
than that
you've got two snappers in the oven
there right yeah that's it there you go
open up a drawer from a team tim yeah
yeah sure you know what you could do
would be nice if you put the spinach on
for me and if they're on all i've got to
do is put them in the window that way
let's go
this time gordon has clearly gotten
through to andy he's on top of the
kitchen again and food is getting to the
dining room quickly
excellent snap was delicious they did a
really good job
[Music]
gordon ramsay is very insightful
he knows andy can cook he knows exactly
what andy needed he saw the rut that
andy was in it's been a dream come true
thank you very much okay
andy no more customers that's it let me
break down yes yeah
after a successful relaunch night in a
restaurant full of vips chef ramsay
wants to have one last word with the
owners
here's the good news about tonight the
relaunch
was a success absolute success not one
plate came back that is incredible
you seriously can cook
but andy here's my confession to you
there's been many times this week that
you frustrated the hell out of me you
know that right
and honestly i finally saw the man i've
been dying to see
you cope brilliantly well you're a
different man you just got on with it
delegated and pushed them
i don't say hello and i don't smile up i
i'm a thinker but i appreciate it i
really do
without you it wasn't possible
we appreciate it i was real down in the
dumps i mean ready to get the hell out
of here but with gordon ramsay being
here this week it's made me think we can
make a better life and a better business
here i just can't wait to get into this
new restaurant that we have
what a long way we have come this week
yeah
take care of that stubborn mule yes
[Laughter]
thank you oh
well done good job
good night good night
up until tonight's dinner service i
really didn't know if any could make
this work and
honestly i'm still not convinced is
where everything here to make this place
a huge success i just hope that his own
stubbornness doesn't get in his way
unbelievable
in the months that followed andy and
ellen continue to embrace chef ramsay's
changes to the one of the fillet sniper
fellow results away la bistro's food is
light and fresh and customers are
thrilled it's delicious
okay well i will let the chef know thank
you very much thank you very much and
there is no better indication of that
than the bistro's repeat business
i think gordon ramsay saw that i was
just doing everything and doing too much
and it was holding me back i'm really
hoping to progress and move on and get
bigger and better gordon ramsay's
welcome here any time here's to the
bistro and new beginnings
[Music]
you